the jurogan experience what's in the bag
bro what's in the bags no the bag what's
in the bag this um this is so this is
something i wanted to bring you to the
towel no that is a what's this medium
adult anus
a 3.5 inch fully dilated regular butt
hole
that's what it really says
so that is a pair of making this up that
is a pair of underwear to sort of i'm
scared to open put on before the box the
contents of this box are entirely
visually pleasing and have been known to
cause a loss of normal bowel function
adult onsen onset pants [ __ ]
please make sure
this disposable underwear is properly
fastened prior to opening the box for
the first time
bro what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
i'm gonna [ __ ] myself and uh i don't
understand how this says medium adult
anus is this just underwear it's
underwear it's like why does it say
media and adult anus
you know your anus is just like a small
that's not i don't know i was just
assuming you were a medium are you not
medium or what's i'm i don't know i have
a big ass
i don't think i fit in these
bro you weren't trying to kill my balls
these are so small
it's cute though
uh so those are the underwear that you
are supposed to put on before opening
the box i'll let you okay
i'm nervous now
i gotta say
that's a first
it says people spring summer collection
to oh [ __ ]
okay i should
i should open this like this
can you uh get it with that camera yeah
i'll be doing over top okay
whoa so this is uh
this is wild
is this an nft
so this is the like this is from the
spring collection that i released this
year um and so yeah this is the sort of
like physical and an nft sort of like
goes with it is that elon musk yeah hulk
gig a chad yeah oh that's hilarious with
a a little um that doggy coin yeah the
dogecoin dog
wow
yeah so this is sort of like um
something that we built in our sort of
like studio
this last year and you sort of like that
one that would be better yeah you can
still kind of see it pretty much as it
is so then it like comes out and you can
like kind of like put that on the like
put the um you hear all the likes coming
out of your mouth
put the
what the [ __ ] is it
put the uh
screen on the like stand there and the
like stand lights up and so this is just
the like box it's the like box just
this is just the box
jesus christ that's an amazing visual
yeah no it definitely elon's gonna see
this and hit the gym he's gonna be like
i gave one to like kimball and and him
yeah yeah yeah i met him in in basel
last week oh no yeah no it's definitely
it's been uh it's been a crazy year this
is super cool and what is this thing on
this side of it what is that so that's
the base that's the like um
the base that you put the the
screen on oh so this comes out pull this
out yeah yeah yeah you put both of them
out oh
and so you pull that up too
yeah
and so there's cords behind that dude
this is so dope and then it like lights
it so if you pull out that cord bag too
so then this too
there's like a
pull that out
that's a hair sample
that's a hair sample yeah
from me
[Laughter]
you have a hair sample there's a hair
sample in there it's a little violet
so it goes on the like the base there
on the base where on the other side
that's where it plugs in
it plugs into the base here do you want
me to grab it real quick does it plug in
back here
that's what kind of
this goes
like this okay and then this goes on
that and then it like plugs in on the
like back here okay take these chords
and like here and when it plugs in it
just lights up is that the idea okay
for folks listening what we have here is
a
no well it's interesting it's uh it
looks like a glass or uh some sort of
plexiglas
yeah some sort of a plastic
um like a mini ipad that has this
beautiful image of a jacked elon musk in
his underwear
i think it's
probably more effort than it's worth to
plug this in
while we're doing the show
good all right perfect
tada and what is this little cord here
this one this extra one that just plugs
into the back of the like
uh screen there oh okay and what does
that do it just powers the screen it the
the screen has like a battery but then
over time it'll over a couple hours
so there
you go
there we go oh and now it's black and
white somehow
it's like going through like kind of
like a loop showing the like sort of
like image and kind of like how the
image was made and sort of
kind of a little bit of the like kind of
behind the scenes pretty dope and what
is this uh q code
so that goes to like my site and you can
kind of see the other people who own
this so this is on the back you can see
see how it's signed it says 60 out of
100. so there's only 100 of these that
exist
and so you've got the like number 61
and like who's got number 69
i'm not sure who has number 69 but
somebody bought number 69 because they
you know wanted because they're silly
yeah but that's very dope yeah that's
right
that's super cool
yeah so this is sort of like one of like
a few different like pieces that were
released in like spring you know and
this was like one of the everydays that
sort of like day okay cool
well thank you very much that's awesome
i appreciate that very dope i'll put
that right there
i don't know if we can keep it on the
desk because it's quite it needs a lot
of attention it does it's definitely
it's something that definitely um i'll
have a spot for it sort of like draws
you in but it it can be it can be a lot
it can be i think it should be right in
front of you jamie like right there
like it's that right there that's not
too bad i have plugs for it that would
work right let me do it yeah
nah we'll keep it here for now but then
after the show it's a big thing it's
pretty dope thank you very much very
cool yeah i appreciate it so how long do
you think you're gonna keep doing this
is this um probably the rest of my life
yeah every day one a day
we got to see it through at this point
through at this point i mean through to
the end on your man on your deathbed
hold on
before you put me in the suicide pod